bien mes chers collègues nous allons
débuter notre réunion et notre première
audition voilà donc nous allons
commencer cette matinée par l'audition
de de monsieur Éric Blachon président et
Renaud Villard directeur général de la
CLAE nationale d'assurance vieillesse
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour
2024 j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site du
Sénat est disponible à la demande si
vous le souhaitez voilà donc monsieur le
Président et Monsieur le Directeur je
vais vous donner la parole très
rapidement afin que vous nous présentier
à la fois l'avis du conseil
d'administration de la caisse sur ce
projet de de de budget mais d'une façon
plus générale les perspective financière
de votre branche qui reste malgré tout
préoccupante d'après les trajectoires
que nous avons qui figurent dans dans
dans le pro j de finance et donc nous
avons besoin d'avoir votre regard et
notamment votre vision sur les effets de
la réforme du printon dernier voilà donc
les membres de la commission ensuite
seront amenés à vous poser des questions
à vous interroger et on commencera bien
entendu par notre rapporteur Pascal
gruni et notre rapporteur général
élisabethe doanau voilà donc maintenant
je vous laisse tout simplement la parole
monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames les rapporteurs euh en propos
liminire je souhaite préciser que le
prier semestre 2023 a été marqué comme
vous le savez par la réforme et puis la
signature d'une convention d'objectif et
de gestion qui a ouvert une nouvelle
période conventionnelle qui va s'étendre
jusqu'en
2027 le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour l'année 2024
impacte peu la branche retraite puisque
il est principalement conent entré
sur des mesures relatives à la fraude
fiscale et à la santé publique avec un
virage préventif réaffirmé et ça nous
concerne un petit peu puisque nous
faisons beaucoup de prévention auprès de
nos senior et avec un un
accès au soins et au au médicaments là
aussi plus prignant il y a aussi dans
ce dans ce C cette loi de finance les
mesures concernant l'assurance chômage
et puis une partie qui vient étauffer
les dispositions relative à la branche
autonomie si les
mesures retraite sont réduites la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
présentée en janvier
2023 et adopté en avril de la même année
comportait euh
avec le relèvement de l'âge de départ de
nombreuses mesures retraite cette
réforme d'ailleurs a rendu nécessaire
quelques adaptations de la législation
retraite qui sont contenu dans le PLFSS
avec pour pfss 2024 avec l'article 9 et
10 où des dispositions de convergence
entre les règles de retraite en vigueur
dans les territoires ultramarins et la
métropole ce sont les article 8 et
40 pour poursuivre
cotecnav nous avons été bien évidemment
saisi du projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour
2024 le 27 septembre le texte a été
examiné lors de la commission
législation du conseil d'administration
de l'Acnav le 3
octobre et puis le Conseil s'est pron
proncé le conseil d'administration s'est
prononcé le 4 octobre et a rendu un avis
majoritairement défavoraable sur 30 voix
l'avis avait 16 voix défavorables 6 sont
pris acte et ce sont
abstenu alors les modification les les
motivations qui expliquent ce ce vote
sont pour les
délégations qui représentent les
salariés une opposition bien évidemment
et vous l'aurez compris une opposition à
la réforme au text qui ne répond pas aux
enjeux de financement de la sécurité
sociale et puis une insuffisance des
moyens dédiés au renforcement de
l'attractivité des métiers de l'aide à
la personne s'agissant des délégations
représentant les employeurs la mise à
contribution des régimes de retraite
complémentairire au financement
de la fin des régimes spéciaux et le
fait aussi
que le projet de texte n'intègre pas la
réforme de l'assiette sociale des
travailleurs
indépendants ça a pesé principalement
sur ce
vote sur la situation financière de la
knnave puisque vous les avez interrogé
là-dessus et du Fond Social de fond de
solidarité vieillesse le de cumulé de de
la cnave et du FSV s'est amélioré en
2022 vous le savez il atteignait 1,6
milliards d'euros après 2,6 milliards
d'euros en 2021 en lien avec le
dynamisme de la masse salariale sous
plafond avec plus 8 % en 2023 le sold de
cumulé knav FSV atteignait un léger
excédent contte tenu de la conjoncture
dynamique une masse salariale sous
plafond de + 7,3
% en 2024 et
2025 le solde sont des hypothèses mais
le solde se dégraderait
significativement avec respectivement
3,8 milliards et 6,4 milliards du fait
d'une revalorisation des pensions
soutenues par l'inflation comme vous le
savez ce sera 5 2 % prévu en janvier
2024 et du ralentissement de la masse
salariale plafonnée à l'horizon
2027 le solde se dégraderait légèrement
le ralentissement de l'inflation
freinerait
simultanément la progression de la masse
salariale et la
revalorisation des pensions l'évolution
des effectif de retraité demeurerit
élevé mais ralenti par la réforme de
2023 nous avons d'ailleurs produit un un
tableau à vos services pour que vous
puissiez voir la trajectoire
20232027 avec deux éléments un avec
réforme et un autre sans réforme alors
pour conclure si la réforme
entraîne une légère dégradation du solde
de la knnave et du Fond Social du fond
de solidarité vieillesse pardon en
2023 en lien avec la mise en œuvre de la
majoration exceptionnel pour les
retraités actuels au-delà la réforme
permettra d'améliorer le solde grâce au
décalage d'âge de départ des assurés
avec une hausse de l'âge légal et la
durée d'assurance qui minorerait les
dépenses versées et réhausseraiit les
recettes perçues c'est C effet et
renforcé par l'attribution de nouvelles
ressources à la branche retraite inscrit
dans cette même
réforme au-delà de 2027 le solde cumulé
knav FSV atteindrait -
11,8 milliards hors réforme contre - 7,4
milliards avec réforme j'en ai terminé
avec ce propos liminaire mais bien évid
éidemment nous restons à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questionsur merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président quelques quelques points
complémentaires et d'abord en rebond
évidemment de ce que vient de souligner
le le président du conseil
d'administration schématiquement si on
se situe à 2030 qui éttaé l'horizon de
pilotage de la réforme des retraites la
dernière on aurait un solde négatif de
10 milliards alors qu'il aurait été de
17 milliards sans réforme le 10 milliard
peut surprendre n'oubliez pas en
revanche que la loi de financement
rectificative ne prévoyez pas de
remettre à l'équilibre le régime général
mais l'ensemble des régimes de retraite
de base et complémentaire et vous savez
que ce sujet a pu susciter quelques
controverses euh vous dire également
monsieur le Président
euh que finalement dans les deux textes
principaux qui nous impactent dans le P
FSS aucun des deux n'appelle de
vigilance particulière en en gestion il
s'agit le président du Conseil
adadministration l'a rappelé de
l'adaptation de la réforme des retraites
pour saint-pierr et Milon et et maotte
texte technique qui a juste en réalité
la LFS lo de financement rectificative à
la réalité de ces deux territoires
ultramarins qui n'appelle pas de
difficulté en terme de mise en œuvre et
le second qui adosse le financement des
régimes des cinq régimes spéciaux mis en
extinction par le financement
rectificative et qui adosse leur soldes
au au régime général là aussi mesure
technique impact financier mais qui en
terme de gestion et de faisabilité
n'appelle aucune vigilance de ma part et
c'est suffisamment rare parce qu'il a
parfois des en pfss des mesures un tout
petit peu techniques et en gestion
question complexe en l'occurrence vous
avez face à vous président un
gestionnaire qui ne se fait pas de
cheveux blancs merci président très bien
c'est une bonne nouvelle merci pour vos
interventions je vais tout de suite
donner la parole tout d'abord à Pascal
gruni puis ellisabeth douau
Pascal merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur alors moi j'ai d'abord une
question sur le montant moyen de la
majoration de pension qui est accordé au
titre du minimum contributif est-ce
qu'il a augmenté le cas échéant quelle
proportion et combien de liquidants ont
effectivement bénéficié de cette
revalorisation de 100 € du minimum
contributif quelle proportion des
assurés ayant liquidé leurs pension
avant le 1er septembre a déjà bénéficier
de cette majoration prévue dans le cadre
de la réforme des retraites pour quel
montant moyen et combien d'entre eux ont
effectivement bénéficier d'une
majoration de 100
€. alors ensuite j'ai une question sur
la GIR
Carco bien
sûr donc parce que vous avez dit que
tout allait bien tout se passait bien et
queil y avait pas pas beaucoup de choses
pas beaucoup de choses mais quand même
nous on entend quand même la partie agir
Arco donc sur cette contribution au
titre de la solidarité financière au
sein du système de retraite et si les
dispositions du PLFSS qui prévoi ce
versement été supprimé ce qui a priori
pour l'instant euh voà on sait pas trop
hein on nous parle d'un amendement qui
arriverait du du gouvernement est-ce que
la ger Carco bénéf disposerait d'un
point de vue juridique de la faculté de
verser de son propre chef une
contribution au régime général et cette
cagnote entre guillemets elle prévoit
quand même les évolutions démographiques
l'espérance de vie c'est pas une
cagnotte c'est en fait une réserve et on
sait très bien que les réserves c'est
plutôt de de la prudence pour pouvoir
verser ensuite au retraiter les les les
pensions auxquelles elles ont elles ont
droit et enfin si vous pouviez nous
parler aussi de la CSG chez les
indépendants en fait du du transfert en
gros hein de la CSG vers vers des droit
retraite
merci très bienabth
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais vous remercier monsieur le
Président ainsi que Monsieur le
Directeur de nous avoir tenu des propos
généraux et là justement on va aller
peut-être un petit peu dans le détail et
donc j'ai deux points à éclaircir le
premier point sur les prévisions en fait
pour 2023 parce que les prévisions de
solde de laacnav et de la branche
vieillesse pour
2023 sont aujourd'hui nettement plus
favorable et c'est ce que vous avez dit
que les prévisions d'il y a un an non
parce que voilà on a un petit peu
l'impression d'un décalage du fait de
recettes qui ont été plus élevées
environ 3 milliards d'euros pour la
knnave comme pour la branche vieillesse
l'écart provient des cotisations
contribution et impôt net pouvez-vous
nous expliquer d'où provient cet
important supplément de recette par
rapport aux prévisions
initiales le deuxième point c'est sur
l'article 10 vous l'avez un petit peu
évoqué donc là du PLFSS 2024 et bien sur
cette article qu'on pourrait qualifier
de tuyau en quelque sorte il comprend un
transfert de 194 millions d'euros de
taxes sur les salaires de la branche
maladie vers la branche vieillesse il
est compensé par une augmentation à du
concurrence de la TVA affectée à la
branche maladie qui est prévu d'ailleurs
par l'article 32 du PLF 2024 et
présenter comme la conséquence des
économies permise par la réforme des
retraites pour le régime de la fonction
publique d'État ce sont des questions
qui reviennent très for fréquemment
quelle est la position de la knnav à ce
sujet nous n'avons pas le souvenir que
le sujet a été évoqué lors de la récente
réforme des retraites qu'en est-il et la
knave a-t-elle joué un rôle dans ce
chiffrage merci merci Madame Donau et je
CIS que Madame grenier av vous aviez
encore une question excusez-moi monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Directeur
j'aurais voulu connaître le le la masse
financière que représentent les pensions
qui sont versées au bénéficiaire qui
résident à
l'étranger et et quelles mesures ont été
mises en œuvre pour la fraude parce
qu'on en parle beaucoup mais finalement
on n' pas voilà concrètement on ne sait
pas où on en est merci voilà monsieur je
vous laisse répondre à ces différentes
questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je je commence peut-être si le
président conseistration est d'accord et
évidemment il complétera et amendera le
le cas échéant je vais essayer de
prendre dans dans l'ordre beaucoup de de
questions j'espère non n'en oublier n'en
oublier aucune euh madame la rapporteur
sur le montant moyen de de de minimum
contributif là pour les nouveaux
retraités ce qu'on observe alors on
l'observe que sur un mois pour le mois
de septembre et conforme aux prévisions
on est sur un peu plus de 30 €
d'augmentation de montant moyen li au
fait que le minimum contributif va
augmenter de 100 € mais rares sont les
assurés qui touchent un mico entier et
donc ce ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui
c'est une augmentation moyenne de de 30
€ qui conforte nos nos prévisions on
était exactement sur sur cette prévision
cette augmentation va aller croissant au
fur à mesure puisque de rénavant le
minimum contributif le montant à et son
plafond sont indexés sur le SMIC et donc
ont une dynamique propre extrêmement
forte euh qui fait que cet écart va se
creuser mais à date ça confirme la
qualité des prévisions et je me tourne
vers mon collègue nathanel grave qui qui
est celui qui a fait absolument toutes
les toutes les prévisions de France et
de Navar sur sur le le le sujet et je
tiens du coup à rendre hommage à lui et
ses et ses équipes euh s'agissant de la
la majoration exceptionnelle donc du du
stock des retraités déjà en en en
paiement et du du de cette augmentation
voulue par financement rectificative euh
à date on a versé cette majoration
majoration exceptionnelle à environ
500000 retraités sur 1,7 million de
retraité donc on sait qu'on a encore 1,2
million de retraité que l'on doit mettre
en paiement avec des travaux techniques
et informatique très lourd à date c'est
un montant moyen de 50 € qui est un peu
inférieur à nos prévisions ce n'est pas
la mauvaise qualité des prévision d'elle
grave qui est en cause c'est le fait que
comme on a servi plutôt les retraités
récents le montant moyen pour les Ret
rités qui sont partis y à 20 ans sera
supérieur et donc on pourra vérifier
expos le montant moyen de 60 € qui a été
prévu aujourd'hui on le sert plutôt aux
jeunes retraités qui ont du coup une
retraite en moyenne plus plus élevée que
que que nos que nos aînés donc environ
500000 bénéficiaires pour un montant
moyen de 50 de 50 € et puis on reste
bien sur cet horizon d' 1,7 million de
bénéficiaires à avant le septembre 2024
sur ceux qui ont touché effectivement
dans ces 500000 le montant ex de 100 €
qui avait fait couler je crois beaucoup
d'encre voire de salive dans la
représentation nationale on à date sur
les 500000 il y en a 20000 qui ont
exactement les les les 100 € puisqu'on
est bien sur là aussi un montant qui est
un montant maximum lié à la durée de
cotisation et au montant de de
retraite s'agissant de de de de de de de
laag Carco
euh deux points que que vous soulevez
madame la rapporteur le premier alors je
vous rejoins entièrement sur le fait que
il s'agit pas de enfin le terme de de
cagnotte en plus peut toujours induire
une forme de confusion chez chez che
chez nos concitoyens ce qu'on constate
en revanche c'est que la réforme des
retraites induit une économie de 3,2
milliards à l'horizon 2030 pour le
régime agir Carco et ensuite en revche
une économie ce n'est pas vous avez
parfaitement raison une une cagnotte les
mots sont sont particulièrement
importants ces 3,2 milliards ensuite
vous avez raison ils appartiennent au
régime complémentairire géré par par les
les partenaires sociaux deux points
malgré tout qui me semblent important et
qui on peut-être été euh pasèrement bien
perçu dans le débat public la knave et
la girir Carco sont deux cousins très
très Germain et plus que Germain puisque
nous avons exactement les mêmes assurés
sont les salariés du secteur privé c'est
la base et la complémentaire la
complémentaire complétant la base et
nous avons une gouvernance
extraordinairement voisine j'ai
l'honneur et la chance à ma à ma gauche
d'avoir un président du conseil
d'administration qui je je me permets de
livrer ce secret qui est un secret
positionessionnel président représente
initialement Force ouvrière et qui est
élu par le paritarisme tout autant avec
une gouvernance et les mêmes
organisations paritaires évidemment côté
knav et côté agiripo donc la guerre
picrocoline n'est pas une guerre
picrocoline puisque en réalité il y a
une bonne entente évidemment entre ces
deux ces deux cousins germains la grande
différence entre la knave et laag Carco
qui peut expliquer c'est ces bizarres de
financement qui fait que l'un finalement
va être à - 100 quand l'autre va être à
+ 10 la grosse différence c'est que sur
les mêmes
assurés nous n'adoptons pas les mêmes
prestations schématiquement si vous êtes
vous êtes au SMIC la knave prend 80 % la
jcco prend 20 % si vous êtes à 4 ou 5
SMIC si vous êtes à 6 ou 7000 € la knave
prend 20 % la girc prend 80 % on a donc
pas les mêmes publics de manière plus
schématique les publics plus fragiles
donc les mécanismes de solidarité sont
plutôt porté par la base et les
mécanismes plutôt contributifs plutôt
portés par la complémentaire mais une
fois qu'on se dit que c'est pas les
mêmes publics on est bien sur des
assurés les mêmes assurés et sur des
gouvernances proches et qui en plus
travaillent très bien ensemble
d'ailleurs sous le contrôle du Pr
conseil d'administration il y a beaucoup
d'administrateurs de laacnave qui sont
administrateurs aussi deag Carco donc en
réalité pour moi il y a un débat
politique mais il y a pas un débat entre
entre organisations je crois que
là-dessus les choses sont plus apaisées
qu' peut qu' ne peut y sembler ensuite
vous m'interrogez madame la rapporteur
sur la faculté juridique juridiquement
effectivement le paréarisme a
parfaitement la la faculté par
convention de décider d'inscrire dans
dans un accord national interpro la
possibilité de contribuer à à tel ou tel
mécanisme de solidarité porté par le le
le régime général euh c'est c'est
juridiquement to totalement possible il
faudrait simplement ensuite un un un un
arrêté d'extension pris par les pouvoirs
publics mais je ne doute pas que si les
partenaires sociaux décident de
transférer de l'argent enfin les
partenaires soci de transférer de
l'argent au régime général enfin sans
évidemment pouvoir me prononcer à la
place des pouvoirs publics j'imagine
difficilement que la vie serait
défavorable mais là je sors de mon mon
rôle et de ma et de ma de ma condition
vous m'interrogez madame la rapporteur
sur la CSG et le ce qu'on appelle le
swap enfin l'échange de CSG pour les
travailleurs indépendants et avec l'idée
finalement dans la les cotisations
auxquelles ils sont assujettis d'avoir
finalement une diminution de la part de
CSG pour améliorer la part consacrée à
la à la retraite la disposition ne
figure pas vous l'avez noté dans le
projet de loi financement deacite
sociale je sais pour pour être au
service également du du cpsti du conseil
de la protection sociale et travailleurs
indépendant que c'est une revendication
fortement portée ass majoritairement par
la gouvernance du cpsti donc par la les
organisations représentatives des
travailleurs indépendants à ma
connaissance le gouvernement a plutôt
une oreille attentive sur le sujet et a
plutôt euh renvoyé je crois ce débat euh
au au au au présent euh débat
parlementairire sur le sur le le le
PLFSS mais en tout cas c'est un sujet
qui est évidemment fortement favorable
aux travailleurs indépendants puisque de
manière très très schématique au risque
maladie dès le 1emier euro vous êtes
couvert le risque retraite chaque euro
supplémentaire améliore évidemment votre
pension contributif et enfin vous
m'interrogez madame la rapporteur sur le
montant des retraites que l'on verse à
l'étranger de mémoire c'est un peu moins
de 4 milliards c'est un montant qui
diminue régulièrement puisque notre
nombre de bénéficiaires à l'étranger
diminue d'années en en en année puisque
finalement il reflète assez largement
l'immigration des des TR glorieuses et
donc des flux migratoires qui sont bien
moindre bien moindre actuellement le
donc on est j'essaie j'avais j'essaie de
retrouver le montant le montant très
précis que je vous donne de mémoire et
ma mémoire fait défaut nathanel tu l'as
en tête 3,8 8 milliards pardon voyez le
j'ai 4 milliards j'étais un tout petit
peu un tout petit peu marseillais 3,8
milliards et ensuite vous m'interrogez
de manière forte sur les diligences que
l'on opère pour éviter que ces 3,8
milliards ne soi fraudés là-dessus euh
3,8 milliards c'est 1,1 million de de de
retraités du système français qui Résid
à l'étranger sur ce 1,1 million 47 %
très précisément bénéficie enfin rentre
dans des échanges d'état civil avec
l'Allemagne l'Italie le Portugal
l'Espagne demain le Danemark et cetera
finalement assez largement la la les
pays européens on a des échanges d'état
civil c'estàdire que tous les mois
l'Allemagne m'envoie ses décès et
réciproquement la France évidemment
enfin le régime général envoie ses dcès
à à l'Allemagne et donc là on a une
viiabilisation à peu près parfaite il
reste 53 % des des des bénéficiaires
pour lesquels on n'a pas ces mécanismes
d'échange d'état civil face à cela on a
une un moyen de maîtrise socle que l'on
complète par des moyens de maîtrise
supplémentaires le socle qui est un
socle robuste mais perfectible c'est
l'obligation tous les ans d'attester son
existence avec un un formulaire que l'on
doit faire remplir par une autorité
d'état civil compétente dont on peut
savoir que parfois et pardon pour le
dire aussi crument moyen en bacich on
peut obtenir le tampon qui va bien dans
ces cadres là on a donc face à ce ce
socle on
rajoute trois étages premier étage c'est
que dans certains pays en particulier de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée et par
que c'est en Algérie que j'ai le plus de
ressortissants du régime de pensionn
français j'ai des collaborateurs qui
convoquent des assurés qui sont payés
pour convoquer des assurés sur pièce et
sur place pour vérifier leur leur
identité en fonction de de risque
deuxème étage que vous avez autorisé
enfin que l'échateteur a autorisé il y a
3 ans qui a mis un peu de temps à à être
performatif c'est la biométrie euh le
décret est sorti l'expérimentation a été
concluante le marché public a été
attribué et donc on devrait passer en en
mode biométrique c'est la biométrie
c'est euh je tous les ans je me filme
avec mon téléphone en le bougeant un peu
pour éviter la photo et puis ça vérifie
un peu comme à l'aéroport vous savez
quand on passe le passeport biométrique
je scanne mon mon passeport biométrique
la l'application va repérer les les
données biométriques je me photographie
enfin je me filme l'application vérifie
la conformité entre la biométrie et les
données sur le passeport et là on a une
fiabilité à 100 % euh là
l'expérimentation donc a été concluante
on le déploie à au printemps pardon 2024
on espère un taux de pénétration assez
bon y compris dans les pays dans en
Algérie parce qu'ils ont un titre
d'identité biométrique depuis très
longtemps depuis bien plus longtemps que
la France en revanche il faut avoir un
smartphone un peu récent donc là on sait
qu'on aura pas une pénétration parfaite
sur des publics parfois un peu âgés et
qui peuvent être éloignés du du du du du
numérique et dans ce cadre-l on ajoute
un un une dernière une dernière
diligence qui pour l'instant fonctionne
plus ou moins bien selon les pays c'est
de l'intermédiation notamment par le
système bancaire c'est-à-dire qu'on
demande aux agences bancaires locales de
convoquer régulièrement sur place les
assurés pour lequels on peut avoir des
des doutes euh on a la chance d'avoir
des partenaires bancaires locaux
relativement bien implantés pour lever
les doutes que l'on que l'on que l'on
peut avoir
euh le l'espoir que je caresse en tout
cas la cible qui est la mienne c'est à
l'horizon 5 ans d'être passé à 60 %
d'échangétatciivil 20 % de biométrique
et d'avoir plus que 20 % de résiduels
sur lesquels je devrais faire du
contrôle sur pièces et et et sur place
parce qu'il est évidemment extrêmement
extrêmement coûteux et et d'éliminer
finalement certificat d'existence papier
qui a le mérite d'exister mais dont on
sait que c'est le moyen de maîtrise le
plus le plus fragile pardon pour la
réponse un peu longue madame la
rapporteur mais vous avez raison c'est
les sujets important et sur lequel on on
on avance de manière têtue et et résolue
madame la rapporteur générale
pardonnez-moi de vous avoir répondu en
en en second euh s'agissant des
prévisions 2023 vous avez raison elles
sont bien meilleures que que que prévu
j'ai que l'essentiel ce et vous l'avez
souligné est lié à la à la très bonne
santé de de la masse de la masse
salariale et donc à une progression plus
rapide que prévu de la masse salariale
on a une sensibilité extrêmement forte à
la masse salariale et à l'inflation et
en l'occurrence cette progression
inattendue en quelque sorte de la masse
salariale nous a été nous avait nous a
été très très favorable vous m'avez
interrogé également sur sur l'article 10
que que nous surnommons comme vous
madame la rapporteur générale l'article
tuyo parce que c'est vraiment de la de
la tuyoterie et sur l'affectation d'une
part supplémentaire de taxes sur les
salaires au au au régime général de
notre point de vue c'est parfaitement
logique et cohérent en quelque sorte que
le régime général récupère une part
supplémentaire de taxe sur les salaires
on est sur un un jeu de de domino qui
finalement vise à affecter le plus
possible la les recettes les recettes
fléchées en fonction du risque
finalement une part croissante de CSG à
la à la à la branche maladie et donc qui
entraîne une part croissante de la taxe
sur les salaires pour la branche pour la
branche autonomie et la branche la
branche GS effectivement on progresse de
4 points sur l'affectation sur la taxe
sur les salaires on passe de 53 à 57 %
ce qui a induit un rendement un
rendement je crois c'est l'
effectivement de 100 millions de 100
millions de d'euros pour nous en tout
cas il n'y a pas d'incohérence en
quelque sorte dans dans cette nouvelle
clé de de répartition qui nous semblait
plutôt plutôt logique les deux grands
gagnants en quelque sorte à cette
nouvelle répartition étant la branche
autonomie et la branche vieillesse et
inversement c'est la branche maladie qui
récupère une fraction supplémentaire de
CS qui du coup elle perd trois points en
terme d'affectation de taxes sur les de
taxes sur les les les les les les
salaires ça revient finalement à faire
un transfert implicite de la branche
maladie vers la vers la branche vers la
la la la branche vieillesse mais qui
nous semble qui nous semble qui nous
semble relativement cohérent après je
pourrais difficilement dire autre chose
puisque c'est une recette supplémentaire
pour le régime général donc je suis
peut-être un tout petit peu biaisé en en
l'occurrence pardonnez-mo monsieur
président avoir été beaucoup trop trop
long dans mes réponses non non c'était
parfait merci beaucoup je vais donner
maintenant la parole à Joceline guidez
pour l'instant la seule qui a demandé la
parole hein voilà ça va être très court
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
savoir quelles sont les actions de la
cnave que que mèent-ell pour simplifier
les démarches et le parcours des
personnes âgées désireuses d'obtenir une
aide financière pour le maintien à
domicile voilà parce que je sais qu'il y
a une demande à ce niveau-là et je sais
pas s'il y a eu des slification et
ensuite s'agissant du plan de lutte
contre la fraude quelles sont vos
actions pour lutter contre le travail
dissimulé et les entreprises éphémère
dont le modèle économique repose
entièrement sur la fraude aux
cotisations et qui organise leur
insolvabilité pour disparaître dès que
le contrôle est
réaliser très bien et moi je rajouterai
également une une question je voudrais
revenir sur les sur les chiffres qui ont
été présentés dans ce dans ce
pfss et vous avez évoqué le niveau de
déficite avec une évolution
qui reste quand même difficile pour les
années qui viennent même si les choses
sont claires la situation été plus
complexe sans réforme mais comment
est-ce que ça se rit en matière de
communication parce que c'est vrai que
d'une façon générale dans l'opinion
publique la réforme de trite devait
entraîner au moins une tendance proche
de l'équilibre même si on était tous
conscient des difficultés là voilà donc
là on va dire que grâce à la réforme
c'est moins pire mais globalement
comment comment comment le traiter en
matière de communication et je vais
aussi donner la parole à Corine fer
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresserait plutôt à monsieur le
Président de la knave concernant les
moyens ou le manque de moyens dédiés au
métier de l'aide aux personnes je suis
plus particulièrement la branche
autonomie mais vous l'avez dit votre
conseil a émis aussi un avis défavorable
et vous vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est
pour cela que je me permets de de
rebondir particulièrement justement sur
par rapport à cette insuffisance de
moyens pour les pour ces MTI où on sait
que non seulement il y a un besoin de de
de d'emplois de nouveaux emplois en très
grand nombre à court terme je ne dis
même plus moyen terme mais à court terme
que dans ce PLFSS on est loin des des
50000 emplois attendus hein on est
plutôt à 3000 4000 pour cette année
nouvelle de de PLFSS et et je souhaitais
si si vous si cela ne ne ne ne vous pose
aucun problème mais je ne pense pas que
vous développiez un peu sur cet argument
qui porte sur l'insuffisance des moyens
dédiés à ces métiers merci je redonne la
parole à Pascal Gruny oui merci moi je
voulais vous demander si vous jugez
utile et même mieux de rendre
obligatoire la fourniture de la preuve
d'existence là des retraités par
biométrie est-ce qu'il faut le rendre
obligatoire en fait et une dernière
question le N nouveau schéma de
financement des régimes
spéciaux fermé dans le cadre de la
réforme des retraites qui prévoit que la
knave devienne équilibrant en dernier
ressort paraît-il financièrement neutre
à long terme pour le régime général
comme l'indique le gouvernement est-ce
que vous ne craignez pas plutôt que la
compensation correspondant au crédit
actuel de la mission régimes sociaux et
de retraite du budget de l'État ne soit
pas revalorisé à hauteur de l'évolution
du besoin de financement des régimes
spéciaux au fil des
années très bien et jene la parole à
Madame
ponemong oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est vraiment qu'une question vous avez
parlé ils était un peu cousin germain de
de la cnave et de la l'Arch Carco moi ce
que j'aimerais savoir c'est que pour
l'argir Carco effectivement il y a à
court terme parce que 2030 c'est presque
à court terme disant un petit moyen
terme des économies substantielles
cependant là les les les travailleurs
qui TR enfin les personnes qui
travailleront 2 ans supplémentaires vont
avoir obtenir aussi des points
supplémentaires hein et si on raésonne à
une enfin sur un peu de façon
assurancielle sur 20 ans quoi en gros
d'espérance de vie à la
retraite il y a ces économies enfin à
terme enfin à terme de de ces 20 ans je
veux dire reviendront en par contre en
dépenses supplémentaires moi j'aimerais
savoir si justement cette élasticité
pour la na je pense que lesffet
l'élasticité entre le fait que pendant 2
ans on travaillait de façon
supplémentaire et les droits AC quiis
les enfin l'augmentation la
revalorisation de de la prestation
retraite et enfin il me semble et
moindre que dans un régime comme l'ARG
Carco qui est relativement proportionnel
puisque bon voilà les points c'est c'est
c'est du volume et qui euh voilà à terme
je je dis bien puisque le calcul cul des
des retraites est un calcul assurenciel
tout bêtement voilà de de l'espérance de
vie à la retraite moi j'aimerais savoir
si vous avez voilà on parle de 2030 ça
me paraît pour l'ARG Carco très court et
j'aimerais savoir la différence
desélticité justement entre les droits
acquis les économies selon le le terme
et les dépenses supp enfin les dépenses
supplémentaires pour la caisse et des
prestations revalorisées pour les pour
les salariés
très bien et finalement oui maintenant
il y a les prises de parole
madamelan après je laisserai
ré merci Monsieur le Directeur vous avez
évoqué l'an dernier devant cette
commission le fait que France service
était le dernier
kilomètre et que vous envisagiez de
développer des entretiens web pour
pouvoir accéder aux pensionnés qui
n'étaient pas accessible d'une autre
façon est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
un retour sur la mise en œuvre de cette
de cet engagement merci monieur je vous
laisse pour les
réponses vous voulez commencer président
allez
allez merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je je vais essayer de les
prendre dans dans l'ordre et pardon si
si j'en oublie sur les les diligences de
de la branche retraite pour simplifier
euh euh les l'accès aux aides pour le
maintien à domicile euh je dirais qu'on
est passé par deux grand chantiers euh
qui qui sont en passe ou qui ont abouti
le premier chantier ça a été la ce que
le chantier qu'on a appelé la demande
unique d'aide des des caisses de
retraite et d'APA qui était un un énorme
chantier qui consistait à pouvoir avoir
un formulaire papier et une demande en
ligne unique pour que l'assurée qui
commence à être fragilisé puisse
finalement demander de l'aide sans se
dire est-ce que c'est c'est le conseil
départemental est-ce que c'est la
caissise de retraite qui est compétente
c'est un formulaire et une demande
unique et ensuite à charge pour les
conseils départementaux ou les caises de
retraite d'effectuer le girage
d'effectuer l'évaluation de la perte
d'autonomie et ensuite de prendre en
charge l'un ou l'autre mais de manière
trans transparente pour pour l'assurer
c'est un projet qu'on a lancé il y a il
y a 3 ans maintenant qui a trouvé son
aboutissement à la fois avec beaucoup de
départements qui ont qui ont été
volontaires avant que ça ne devienne
obligatoire en quelque sorte dorénavant
on a bien un formulaire unique au sens
administratif du terme qui du coup étant
encore en quelque sorte le dispositif
c'est depuis cet été que l'arrêté créant
ce formulaire unique a facilité la
démarche mais avant même finalement le
côté un peu normatif de l'organisation
on avait réussi à à à à partager ces
données à la fois numériques avec un
service en ligne avec un certain nombre
de département un peu moins peut-être et
le formulaire papier avec un nombre
élevé de département c'est un dispositif
qui repose beaucoup aussi sur une forme
de confiance mutuelle c'est pour ça
qu'il a fallu du temps et qu'il faut
faudra encore du temps puisque ça
suppose que l'évaluation de l'un soit
opposable à l'autre deuxième clé de
confiance mutuelle ça suppose que l'un
ou l'autre des acteurs qui a reçu la
demande prennent en charge la demande
commence à engager un financement ou un
soutien quitte ensuite à passer en
quelque sorte l'assurer auprès du
Conseil départemental ou auprès de la de
la de la caisse de retraite mais c'est
un chantier qui à mes yeux est est un
chantier potentiellement majeur deuxième
volet de simplification qui concerne
pour le coup l'aménagement du
l'adaptation du logement au au
vieillissement puisque on avait deux
acteurs qui étaient étroitement
coordonnés l'ANA l'agence nationale
d'amélioration de l'habitat et et la
knnave qui cinancer l'adaptation du
logement au vieillissement il y aura
dorénavant un guichet unique euh sous le
nom de ma cri adapte MPa qui devrait
être lancé en 2024 et bien entendu le la
la knav transférera ses financements
dédiés à l'ANA pour qu'elle puisse
porter ce ce ce guichet unique et je
salue l'initiative même si évidemment ce
n'est plus la knaf qui sera le guichet
on sera en revanche évidemment le
guichet humain puisque les retraités
fragilisés qui feront faire une douche
italienne auront un accompagnement
social par le biais évidemment des
équipes de de de l'Assurance Retraite
donc c là c'est une à mes une vraie
simplification qui reprend un peu le
modèle et j'espère de manière encore
plus robuste ma prime réve on est sur
cette même logique donc deux avancées à
mes yeux significatives mais qu'il
faudra sans doute évaluer sur monsieur
le Président sur le niveau de de de de
déficit et le fait qu'effectivement il y
a eu une forme peut-être de de
difficulté dans dans dans le dans le
débat public sur Y y a-t-il un déficit
finalement il y a-t-il un retour à
équilibre avec peut-être des j'oserais
pas dire des jeux d'acteur mais en tout
cas une lisibilité ou des discours en
tout cas parfois contradictoires sur il
n'y a pas déficit donc il n'y a pas
d'urgence à agir il y a moins de déficit
il y a plus de déficit de fait je peux
comprendre nos concitoyens qui sont un
tout petit peu perplexe face à ce sujet
le drame surtout pour moi et vous
l'évoquez c'est un suet de communication
le drame c'est les jeunes générations
qui ont l'impression de cotiser à perte
et quand on cotise à perte vous le savez
tous hein tous et toutes pardon c'est
quasiment 30 % du salaire qu'on met pour
payer sa retraite enfin pour payer la
retraite de ses aînés si on a
l'impression de se faire voler pardon 30
% pour soimême n'avoir pas de retraite
le consentement républicain à l'impôt et
au prélèvement peut être sérieusement
réinterrogé je pense qu'effectivement il
faudra réapaiser en quelque sorte et
trouver les moyens euh d'une d'une
communication apaisante de montrer que
la dernière réforme comme les réformes
qui l'ont précédé a contribué fortement
à réduire le besoin de financement mais
que ce besoin de financement c'est bien
pour ça que l'horizon de la réforme et
vous l'avez souigné madame francément
j'ai un horizon de moyen terme euh le
besoin de financement au-delà de 2030-
2040 n'est pas n'est pas encore
complètement n'est pas encore
complètement couvert faut pas oublier
cette réalité c'est qu'en 2070 qui est
un peu enfin qui est aprèsdemain pour un
régime de retraite en 2070 avec la
démographie actuelle qui n'est pas
fameuse fameuse sur le plan de naissance
le ratio cotisant retraité atteint le
chiffre fatidique de 1 ça veut dire que
chaque actif porte sur ses épaules un
retraité aujourd'hui c'est 1,4 ça fait
30 % de cotisation à un pour un euh et
donc et je je je ne dis pas ça pour dire
qu' enfin en tout cas le politique au
sens large les différentes majorités se
sont emparés du sujet avec je crois
résolu ution et
courage sur le les les les moyens la
branche à domicile c'est le président
qui qui a été interpellé je je je je ne
réponds pas sur les madame la rapporteur
sur est-ce qu'il faudrait un jour que
les les la biométrie soit soit
obligatoire je pense que ce serait
souhaitable dans un horizon sans plus
lointain parce qu'il faut quand même un
équipement en smartphone une couverture
en en réseau en réseau et et des des
titres biométriques clairement c'est un
horizon c'est un horizon qui qui doit
être souhaitable l'avantage en tout cas
déjà de la biométrie quand on est sur
des pays qui en fait parce qu'il y a pas
besoin d'avoir un iPhone récent il faut
avoir un smartphone et un titre
biométrique l'avantage c'est que la
couverture des smartphones et des titres
biométriques n'est pas si ridicule à
l'étranger et que l'assuré qui de 70 ans
refusera de passer par la biométrie
nécessairement bénéficiera de nos soins
attentionnés que de ce fait finalement
entre être convoqué sur pièce sur place
devoir faire 200 km en voiture avec sa
identité son certificat de naissance au
bout d'un moment je dis pas qu'on va
faire exprès d'être contraignant mais au
bout d'un moment la simplicité peut pe
peut l'emporter inversement quelqu'un
qui au bout de 3 4 5 ans refusera cette
simplicité on pourra s'interroger sur
les moyens qui le conduisent à refuser
cette simplicité et peut-être qu'à un
moment il faudra être plus plus
incitatif plus incitatif encore sur le
nouveau schéma de financement des
régimes spéciaux le risque le risque
existe vous avez je vous rejoins
entièrement madame le rapporteur euh on
parle en plus en milliard d'euros
surtout sur le régime SNCF de mémoire le
régime SNCF en projection euh il est à 4
ou 5 milliards d'euros de déficit d'ici
d'ici 20 ans pour moi la meilleure
garantie euh au-delà du fait que la loi
dit bien que évidment les financements
et et l'effort financiers de l'État pour
combler les déficit des résimes spéciaux
sera transféré la meilleure garantie
c'est la transparence la meilleure
garantie c'est vous et la de financement
d'ailleurs prévoit que chaque année la
LFSS vous rende compte et rende compte à
travers vous évidment à nos concitoyens
et concitoyennes rendre compte de cette
de ce transfert financier je connais pas
de meilleure garantie que la que la que
la la transparence et la vigilance des
parlementaires évidemment que vous êtes
du conseil d'administration et puis sans
doute aussi de de de l'opinion publique
pour éviter finalement une espèce de
transfert sauvage que je neurais saurais
imaginer entre l'État et la et la
sécurité sociale sur
l'élasticité madame P sur la
l'élasticité finalement est-ce que bout
du
bout le régime complémentaire ne va pas
être finalement beaucoup moins gagnant
entre guillemets que prévu à à la
réforme puisqu'il va verser des
retraites plus importantes C eff nororia
lié à la réforme qui fait que le montant
des retraites moyen va augmenter il se
vérifie à peu près dans les mêmes
proportion au régime général l'impact
financier de la réforme il est
suffisamment il est il est tel qu'il
permet de compenser le fait que le
montant moyen des pensions va augmenter
et de manière relativement significatif
parce que vous l'avez rappelé on
travaille 2 ans de plus en revanche on
va servir la retraite 2 ans de moins et
donc là où on servait une retraite 24
ans le décalage fait qu'on va la servir
22 ans et c'est là que se situe le gros
de l'économie si vous servez pendant 22
ans une retraite majorée de 3 % vous
avez quand même une économie qui est
très très significative l'élasticité du
régime complémentaire est légèrement
plus forte mais en réalité pas pas tant
que pas tant que pas tant que cela euh
euh donc on a on constate le le même
effet et et la réforme mécaniquement
sans au-delà des coups de pouce et
cetera la réforme mécaniquement augmente
de 3 % le montant- moyen des pensions
indépendamment des coups de pous du
minimum contributif mais parce que juste
vous l'avez rappelé on travaille plus on
cotise plus et donc la moy montant moyen
de la retraite
est est accru en revanche les économies
sont générées par le fait que malgré
cette augmentation significative du
montant moyen des retraite l'espérance
de service de la retraite se retrouve
réduite de de 2 ans c'estàdire qu'on va
rester sur un montant moyen aujourd'hui
on ver une retraite en moyen de 22 ans
on va rester autour de 22 23 ans avec la
réforme alors que finalement
l'espériance de vie fait qu'on sera
passé à 22 23 24 ans et c'est là que sur
un calcul actuariel évidemment vous avez
un impact financier euh significatif
euh et euh et enfin pardon madame la
sénatrice sur les les les les Fran
services oui on commence à tester à la
fois des entretiens web j'ai pas de de
bilan complet à la fois des entretiens
web et y compris des projections
d'agents euh dans certaines Fran
services qui tournent qui tournent bien
sur des des des des des expimentations
de rendez-vous ce qu'on est en train de
de de de regarder avec les Fran services
c'est la capacité à ce que les agents
des Franic prennent directement
rendez-vous pour nous parce
qu'aujourd'hui le frein qu'on constate
c'est je vais en Fran service je dis
j'aimerais bien avoir rendez-vous avec
la branche retraite l'agent du Fran
service ne peut pas prendre rendez-vous
pour nous et donc l'assurée est obligé
soit d'aller sur sur l'appli soit
d'apper le 3960 et donc finalement
l'agent de France service se sent un peu
délégitimé en quelque sorte on est en
train regarder si si on peut pas quand
je dis on c'est parce que c'est
évidemment l'ensemble des des opérateurs
de France service de regarder si on peut
pas faire un peu un lot réservataire de
rendez-vous pour les Francs services qui
puissent du coup positionner eux-mêmes
ce qui valoriserait du coup leur action
et et donnerait satisfaction à l'assurer
c'est des travaux qui sont qui sont
conduits par la NCT et fortement pilotés
par par Stanislas Guerini qui nous
réunit très souvent sur sur ces sujets
de simplification en quelque sorte donc
c'est un sujet qu'on suit de de très
près d'autant que vous avez tous tous et
toutes pris connaissance du rapport du
Conseil d'État sur les derniers
kilomètres qui pour le coup fournit
aussi je trouve des pistes des pistes
intéressantes et qui saluent justement
le rôle des Fran services mais ce rôle
encore à faire à à développer sur le
dernier kilomètre des des des Fran
services c'est le rapport tout récent de
la section des rapports du du du du
Conseil d'État qui d'ailleurs salue
plusieurs fois l'action de la CNAF donc
je ne peux que citer cet excellent
rapport merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Président je CIS que vous vouz
intervenir je vais intervenir sur
plusieurs éléments qui ont
été posés comme question euh la
simplification des démarches je crois
que sur la simplification des démarches
si si vous avez l'occasion de regarder
ce qui ce qu'on a contracté à travers la
convention d'objectif et de gestion on
est dans cette volonté de de simplifier
grandement la relation avec avec nos
assurés alors dans plusieurs domaines
parce que le conseil
d'administration reproche à cette
désincarnation de la relation avec avec
son public et a pris la la l'engagement
d'arriver à un nombre de rendez-vous qui
serait la cible c'est 1 million en fin
de COG aujourd'hui on doit être de
mémoire 300 450000 rendez-vous donc vous
voyez qu' y a une ambition de
d'accroître cette relation avec avec nos
nos assurés à travers cette cette
relation pour pouvoir
traiter les problèmes de nous assurer
parce que ce qui ce qu'il faut
comprendre au niveau du conseil nous
s'attache pas trop au train qui
arrivrive à l'heure ça nous intéresse
pas ce qui est ce qui est important pour
nous c'est voir comment on peut
améliorer les situations qui sont
souvent décricriés malheureusement et et
mal à propos très souvent dans la presse
ou à travers les médias qui
ont des intentions qui nous fragilisent
et et c'est là-dessus qu'on on met on
met beaucoup l'accent pour ce qui est de
l'accompagnement des des personnes alors
on n'est pas les seuls acteurs dans dans
dans la dans dans l'affaire puisque vous
savez aussi bien que moi qu' on dépend
aussi des conseills départementaux pour
pouvoir mener des
actions de de qualité pour nos assurés
on a une réflexion
actuellement dans notre commission
d'action sanitaire et sociale pour voir
quel est le le montant qu'on pourrait
donner à nos dans le cadre de nos
prestations parce qu'on voudrait pas que
ce soit soit utilisé à des fins de
surenchère et et
que l'initiative prise soit pas
suffisamment pertinente pour pouvoir
accompagner les les les personnes qui
sont au service de nos seniors on sait
très bien et c'est il y a eu des
rapports très intéressants sur le sujet
qu'il y a un problème avec les aides à
domicile on en est grandement conscient
et on est on on essaie de voir comment
on peut
euh relever ce ce niveau de de
rémunération donné à ces personnes pour
pouvoir avoir une une qualité une
qualité à la hauteur des des besoins
donc voilà un petit peu l'esprit dans
lequel on travaille aujourd'hui et ce
que l'on est en train de de construire
pour pouvoir répondre à ce ce
problème monsieur le directeur c'est
juste pour apporter le chiffre que que
que vous cherchez monsieur le Président
le le làdessus he pour aller dans le
sens du président le cons Conseil a
directement adopté dès 2022 un
relèvement de 14 et5i% de son tarif pour
s'aligner sur l'avenant 43 de la branche
d à domicile pour le coup le Conseil
administration a été très vigilant pour
justement soutenir cet accord des des
partenaires sociaux visant à revaloriser
le le tarif de la de la branche d'aide
d'aide à domicile pour le coup le
là-dessus l'encre enfin le je sais pas
si c'est la décision du
conseiladministration n'a ni tardé ni ni
trembler 2022 pardon je voulais apporter
cette précision président merci Monsieur
le Directeur euh bon je crois que j'ai
c'est ce que je voulais apporter comme
complément oui et puis et puis sur le
problème de laag Carco il y a aussi le
déplacement des déplacement des
générations qui va nous faire quand même
aussi gagner un petit peu sur sur les
les les points qui seront acquis malgré
tout très bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur il nous reste à
vous remercier pour votre vos
interventions et d'avoir répondu aux
questions des différences sénateur voilà
donc nous allons clôturer merci bien
cette audition euh et ensuite j'ai deux
trois